[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler d'un projet
que j'ai commencé il ya une dizaine
d'années qui s'appelle humanité
végétales petit historique sur le projet
c'est un projet que j'avais commencé
ensuite une exposition à la maison
d'ailleurs à yverdon qui s'appelait
monde miroir ensuite on voulait faire
tout un travail sur les jardins utopique
du début xxème siècle et fin du 19e
siècle mais à ce moment là était
inaugurée avec une communication assez
science-fictionnel une banque de graines
asthme hallebardes dans les glaces
financé par les gouvernements
scandinaves et par les grandes
fondations type rockefeller et bill
gates et on se pose la question je vous
posais la question de savoir comment
introduire une utopie scientifique dans
un travail qui concernait ses jardins
formidable ces jardins utopique réalisé
par des gens avec leur force intérieure
et qu'ils ont avec un monde intérieur
donner une forme à travers un jardin
travers une construction et pour moi
c'était le début de très très nombreuses
lectures j'ai abordé la question
beaucoup plus large de toute la relation
au végétal je suis aussi allé visiter
cette utopie scientifique à svalbard et
qui était vraiment quelque chose de très
important aujourd'hui mais qui est
encore beaucoup plus important de ce qui
se passe ailleurs dans les autres
banques de graines par rapport à la
nécessité de préserver la mémoire
génétique des plantes et notamment des
plantes alimentaires
ce travail m'a conduit aussi à traiter
j'dirais d'une façon générale la
question du végétal la question de
l'origine l'origine de la vie aussi
ce premier micro organismes qui possède
avant d'être divisés dans les dix ans
rien qu'on connaît lé règne animal le
règne végétal reine des champignons
possède toutes ces informations
et suite à son évolution ses trois
grandes branches sont définis
aujourd'hui sur la planète comme élément
de la vie fondamentale mais j'aime bien
rappeler petite histoire de richard
whisky dit le premier petit micro
organismes qui est sorti des boues
primaire pour donner forme à la vie s'il
n'avait pas désobéi à ses parents il n'y
aurait pas de vie sur la terre et il
ajoute c'est grâce à ses larmes qu'il
était proche il qu'ils étaient protégés
du rayonnement solaire donc aujourd'hui
si la vie existe sur la terre si on
existe quelque part c'est grâce à la
désobéissance et grâce aux larmes
après évidemment je me suis intéressé à
la question de l'origine des plantes
comme vous le savez sans doute sur la
planète existe des centres des plantes
alimentaires par exemple les forêts de
pommiers sauvages au kazakhstan sont le
sang d'origine des pommes ce qu'il faut
s'imaginer sait qu avant l'invention du
bateau n'y avait pas de pommes aux états
unis et que petit à petit les plantes
alimentaires les pommes qui était au
kazakhstan d'où des forêts de pommiers
qui existe encore aujourd'hui les
tomates et les pommes de terre qui en
parenthèses sont à même espèce viennent
du du pérou et c'est à travers les
ventes à travers les circulations dos à
travers l'air les oiseaux et ensuite à
travers les échanges des humains que
petit à petit des plantes au coloniser
la planète
donc je me suis intéressé à toute cette
histoire et j'ai découvert au cours de
mon travail
l'institut vavilov à saint pétersbourg
qui est la plus ancienne banque de
graines au monde
80% des variétés qui sont dans cette
banque de graines n'existe nulle part
ailleurs créé par nikolaï vavilov qui
est né en 1875 et nicolas et nikolaï
vavilov choisi l'agronomie et la
génétique parce que il veut résoudre les
problèmes de famine endémique aux nuits
dans ses rangs russie vous savez quand
aussi 19e siècle il ya quelquefois 700
800 mille morts de faim dans les
campagnes et il se dit mais vraiment une
conviction profonde je dois trouver une
solution pour résoudre ses problèmes
alimentaires et il choisit la génétique
l'agronomie il se forme auprès des
grands agronome européen des généticiens
et il a découvert sur la planète
recettes des centres d'origine de toutes
les des plantes alimentaires
aujourd'hui on détermine 8 et il fera à
peu près 200 expéditions à travers la
planète dont 340 en dessous territoire
russe est une soixantaine à l'étranger
financé par lénine est soutenu par le
régime de l'époque mais quand staline
arrive au pouvoir grandes dissensions
entre vavilov et lyssenko et staline
pourquoi parce que la question de la
génétique est quelque chose qui n'est
pas acceptée par la danse et du
matérialisme c'est à dire que on pense
que c'est dans le matériel du ces les
conditions extérieures qui vont
déterminer comment peut être une plante
mais aussi comment peut être un homme
avec des catastrophes qu'on connaît avec
cette idée donc vavilov après avoir fait
cette expédition je vous dirais
quelque chose d'incroyable aujourd'hui
dans la banque de graines de lin stephen
dorff à saint pétersbourg ses cinquante
mille variétés de blé c'est quatre mille
cinq cents variétés de pommes de terre
c'est 800 variétés de cassis et c'est un
trésor absolument exceptionnel qui est
dans cet institut qui travaillent dans
des conditions comme vous le voyez
extrêmement modeste donc je reviens en
arrière et quand de davidoff accusés par
staline d'être causeur en fait de
l'échec du plan quinquennal il est
condamné à la prison à vie et ensuite
une fois qui l'emprisonnaient il est
condamné à mort et en 1943 la ville of
avait demandé en 41 que sa condamnation
à mort soit perpétuée en une peine à
perpétuité emprisonnement à vie
en 43 et meurent de faim dans les
prisons de staline aujourd'hui
l'institut vavilov continue d'y exister
continue son travail continu de
régénérer les différentes variétés
est ce qui est très important c'est que
l'esprit de la ville offre existe encore
de cet institut et c'était de dire pour
préserver la mémoire génétique des
plantes cultivées il faut les régénérer
en chant et pour préserver la mémoire
génétique des plantes qui sont
alimentaires l'état sauvage il faut
préserver ses état sauvage pour pas
qu'ils aient des influences de l'homme
d'affluence de croisement artificielle
par rapport à l'évolution et le travail
qui est fait de synthés ch'ti tu es
vraiment fondamental par rapport à
l'avenir aujourd'hui de la planète parce
qu'on est confronté à des changements
climatiques on est confronté à des
changements géologiques on est
confrontés à toutes sortes de problèmes
et on doit trouver des variétés qui
peuvent se développer et qui peut être
adapté à ces nouvelles conditions
important pourquoi parce que autre
aspect que j'ai abordé aussi d'en
démontrer et la question des villes je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya une grande
fragmentation entre la ville et la
campagne
mais les villes pose aussi d'énormes
problèmes comment nourrir des mégapoles
de 45 millions d'habitants qui sont deux
sur des surfaces bétonnées avec des gens
très concentré qui n'ont pas les moyens
de cultiver ou les chansons plus en plus
éloignés j'ai appris récemment comme
information par le professeur frison qui
est entre autres dans le conseil
d'administration des deux banques degré
un cheval barbe
suite à une étude 70 % des gaz à effet
de serre produits par les sommes
proviennent du transport de
l'alimentation donc comment faire
comment résoudre les problèmes dans ces
villes comment est-ce qu'on doit se
poser la question pour m deux vivent au
centre
de nos préoccupations et pas mettre
uniquement l'économie pas raisonner par
rapport uniquement un profit immédiat et
je crois que cette question du vivant de
vivant au centre de penser quelque chose
de fondamental absolument à présent à
tout niveau par rapport à l'avenir donc
travailler dans la ville s'était montré
aussi les différents aspects et il ya
des aspects très intéressant dans les
villes par exemple dans les villes
portugaise à lisbonne les plates-bandes
les parcs des cas un endroit qui est pas
cultiver et ben on laisse les gens
planter leurs shoots noter leurs salades
toutes et leurs carottes et ça permet à
des gens qui ont peu de moyens d'avoir
des la subsistance et aimer le jardin
c'est pas que la subsistance et du lien
social aussi c'est du plaisir et c'est
une relation à la terre c'est aussi une
façon de garder en contact avec ce qui
nous fait vivre et ce qui génère la vie
est aujourd'hui dans dans les villes
c'est vrai que il ya des jardins sur les
toits mais moi je pense que c'est un peu
des sparadraps qui permettent plus une
prise de conscience qu'ils sont très
positives d'ailleurs de pouvoir penser à
comment est ce qu'on peut se retrouver
comment est-ce qu'on peut retrouver
cette racine par rapport à nos 10 par
rapport aux décisions qu'on apprend que
sur l'environnement autre aspect aussi
que j'ai traité parce que j'ai pas
séparer le végétal entre un végétal
botanique ornementale médicinales non
pour moi le végétal c'est un potentiel
de molécules qui une fois pouvaient être
utiles une fois pouvait donner un légume
à manger pour une fois une plante à
soigner et dans l'histoire de des
jardins botaniques on retrouve toute
cette histoire toute cette histoire du
du savoir où les premiers jardins
botaniques était on peut dire que le
premier jardin botanique étaient des
jardins de plantes médicinales mais
avant ces gens-là botanique de plantes
médicinales
c'était des guérisseurs c'était les
chamans c'était en fait un savoir
populaire qui connaissait le végétal qui
connaissait atlan connaissait les
facultés et les caractéristiques des
plantes qui nous permettait de nous
soigner ou de faire différentes choses
des jardins botaniques ont une mission
qu'ils remplissent toujours aujourd'hui
une mission donc de préservation une
mission de savoir une mission
d'éducation et d'histoire du jardin
botanique
elle est vraiment formidable je trouve
parce que non seulement il ya toutes les
plantes que l'on voit que nos visites
des jardins botaniques mais il ya aussi
tout le savoir accumulé
qui se trouve dans les réserves dans les
bibliothèques dans les dessins
extraordinaire de plantes qui date
depuis très très longtemps
donc voilà pour moi j'ai aussi aborder
cette question du jardin botanique mais
aussi avec un aspect très intéressant
dans l'histoire de la botanique c'est
que il ya aussi des botanistes amateurs
passionnés qui ont apporté des
informations incroyable il ya un
botaniste amateurs près de la
chaux-de-fonds qui a trouvé 174 nouveaux
miclo mis 7 et qui les a identifiés
c'était d'écouter des mecs ont mis cinq
ans et des petits champignons petit
transit sûr qu'on connaissait absolument
pas avant voilà après tout un autre
aspect aussi extrêmement important qui
est toute la recherche agronomique
aujourd'hui pour résoudre les questions
alimentaires pour résoudre les questions
du développement de nouvelles variétés
parce que nous sommes dans cette
situation aujourd'hui les conditions
climatiques modifient complètement toute
la culture toutes les cultures pour deux
aspects d'une part en intrants se
rendent compte que tout l'agrochimie qui
était développée essentiellement depuis
le début du 20e siècle mais surtout
après la guerre est en train de faire
l'effet contraire de ce qu'on pensait
qu'elle allait produire c'est à dire
augmentation de la productivité mais
aujourd'hui les sols deviennent stériles
et ya des sols qui sont nourris pas avec
des engrais qui sont plus en plus fort
ne donne rien une grande ceinture morte
aux états unis sur des centaines de
kilomètres de les terrains sont morts et
je pense qu'à une chose importante
comment parle d'alimentation et
d'agriculture c'est quelque part c'est
pas le paysan qui nous nourrissent c'est
la terre et si la terre est morte si en
amont paysans ça sert à rien dans tout
le travail aujourd'hui des instituts de
recherche qui est nouveau parce que en
moins donné en a confié quand même au
pouvoir central au pouvoir politique et
aux scientifiques
l'évolution d'agriculture en donnant ses
orientations qui était une orientation
purement économique est aujourd'hui dans
les centres de recherche une prise de
conscience en train d'émerger et on
cherche de nouvelles variétés en cherche
à diminuer les engrais en cherche à
diminuer les intrants on cherche des
méthodes alternatives là comme avec les
punaises ont fait pondre des mouches sur
le dos des punaises et l'oeuvre de la
mouche pour se nourrir pénètrent
l'intérieur de punaises et là tu sais un
peu les méthodes alternatives qui sont
assez terrible mais qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui pour éviter l'emploi de
pesticides et de l'emploi de produits
chimiques
toute cette recherche agronomique
aujourd'hui donne cette cette nouvelle
orientation qui est extrêmement
intéressante avec une liaison qui se
fait aussi avec les instituts
universitaires sur une recherche végétal
plus fondamentales sur une recherche sur
le système de fonctionnement les plantes
sur comment une plante se défend par
exemple l'envoi que si on agresse une
feuille s'il peut être attaqué par une
chenille ou comme ça il ya un signal
électrique qui part de la feuille du
lieu de l'agression et qui va jusque sur
la tige à une certaine vitesse mais
quand le signal électrique arrive sur la
tige ce signal électrique accélère pour
donner l'information à toute la plante
est à ce moment certaines plantes génère
des toxines pour éviter d'être agressé
par d'autres
voilà c'est un grand tour d'un grand
panorama c'est vrai que j'ai travaillé
pendant dix ans est là pour être
extrêmement synthétique il ya des choses
là qui me touche énormément
autant dans les jardins utopique que
doit les personnes qui s'engagent et à
travers ce grand voyage végétal ce grand
périple j'ai rencontré julio mco qui est
un paysans péruviens qui travaillent à
4800 m d'altitude
c'est à dire sept sommets du mont blanc
et cultive 380 variété de pappas
primitive as c'est à dire des pommes de
terre primitive qui font partie de
l'agriculture et de la culture des incas
et qu'il a par intuition par générosité
par envie qu'il a décidé de sauvegarder
il avait repris l'exploitation de son
père où il y avait 80 variétés d'huiles
en a380 et c'est formidable
comment l'énergie d'une personne arrive
en fait a bouleversé des montagnes à
faire des collections incroyable est-ce
qu'il faut savoir avec la pomme de terre
c'est que les pommes de terre elles
germent donc si on les replante pas
chaque année toute la collection est
fichu donc ça veut dire que chaque année
il faut les récolter faut trouver les
meilleurs spécimens il faut les
préserver mais que dont dépend aussi la
nourriture en prend des on a trouvé une
méthode est de nouveau je rejoins
savoirs populaires que j'aime beaucoup
ce savoir paysan qui ont fait à la base
de toutes les variétés on connaît par
rapport aux croisements et tous et ses
différents aspects d'améliorer les
variétés et là ils ont trouvé une
méthode extraordinaire pour que les
pommes de terre puis se conserver sans
germes et c'est à dire que
étant des pommes de terre au sol il est
foule dense au dessus et il les laisse
qu'un jour reposer après qu'un jour ils
les placent dans des sacs qui place ses
sacs pendant huit jours dorés dans un
ruisseau d'eau fraîche et après il sorte
que les sacs il étala n'ouvre les pommes
de terre chez le sol et les pommes de
terre deviennent tout glisse comme des
cailloux enrobé d'une jolie farine grise
et on peut les garder trois quatre ans
il suffit d'y replonger dans une soute
dans un liquide et on a sauvegardé en
fait ce moyen cette solution pour
pouvoir à manger sur deux trois quatre
ans voilà ben écoutez j'ai fait un
résumé et je place vraiment vraiment
vraiment toute cette démarche au coeur
pour que le vivant soit vraiment coeur
de nos préoccupations parce que je pense
que si on met l'humain au centre de nos
préoccupations et comme facteur
principal du développement
c'est la porte ouverte à l'entrepôt
scène alors que le vivant c'est quand
même assez beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]